formation this commitment goes straight
to the top
the president and I had been speaking
regularly about this outbreak and I have
been speaking with the senior officials
at HHS and the White House multiple
times each day since the outbreak began
to represent an international threat the
president is highly engaged in this
response and closely monitoring the work
we're doing to keep Americans safe I'll
give you a brief sense of the work being
done across HHS beyond the CDC
activities that I've mentioned our
emergency response arm the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
or asper is assessing the level of
preparedness we have with the strategic
national stockpile which includes
pharmaceuticals and other necessary
medical supplies HHS's administration
for children and families is working
with the State Department to assist any
Americans who will need assistance being
repatriated to the United States NIH
asper and FDA are pursuing research into
and assessing the possibilities for
vaccines diagnostics and therapeutics
which is necessarily a longer-term
project in addition to the work being
done in government there are basic
precautions all Americans can take
healthcare providers should be on the
lookout for patients with travel history
to China especially who Bay province and
for relevant symptoms late on Monday the
CDC in the State Department issued a
level-3 travel advisory for all of China
this higher level of alert means that
Americans should reconsider or postpone
travel to any part of China the State
Department has also maintained what they
call a level four warning for who Bay
meaning Americans should not travel
there in closing I'll remind the
American people one more time we are
working hard to keep you safe we are
constantly preparing for the possibility
that the situation could worsen and your
health and safety has been and will be
our top priority to discuss more about
the current state of the epidemiology
and CDC's work I will now hand things
over to CDC's director dr. Robert
Redfield thank you
Thank You mr. secretary and thank all of
you for joining us here today as we
discuss the
latest developments that are involved in
this situation it is a rapidly changing
situation in the United States and
throughout the global community right
now we know of 18 international
locations that have identified cases of
this new virus including the United
States to better protect the health of
the American public during the emergence
of this novel coronavirus and based on
the evolving information from China
CDC has reassessed its entry strategy
and decided to expand to screening
travelers from the five airports
originally 220 airports in the United
States my thoughts and prayers are with
all the health care providers and
frontline responders that are handling
this public health threat as well as the
people of China I know that many
Americans may be worried about the virus
and I wanted to let them know a few
things that they can do everyone has a
role to play in helping contain the
spread of this virus CDC in conjunction
with the State Department has updated
our travel guidance and now recommends
that travelers avoid unnecessary travel
to China it's currently the flu season
in respiratory disease season and
there's a lot of respiratory disease out
in our nation we recommend washing of
the hands covering your mouth mouth when
you cough staying at home if you're sick
for health care providers we ask them to
be on the lookout for people with the
travel history from China especially who
Bay province if they develop fever and
respiratory symptoms and if you're a
health care provider that's caring for a
confirmed patient we ask you to follow
the recommended infection control
procedures for all people that may have
this infection we ask you to follow the
CDC guidance and how to reduce the risk
of spreading your illness to others and
for people who have may had close
contact with someone who was a confirmed
patient we asked them also to follow
that guidance and if you have symptoms
contact your healthcare provider right
now there is no spread of this virus in
our communities here at home this is why
our current assessment is that the
immediate health risk of this new virus
to the general public is low in our
nation the coming days and weeks are
likely to bring more confirmed cases
here and around the world including the
possibility of some person to person
spread but our goal of the ongoing u.s.
public health response is to contain
this outbreak and prevent sustained
spread of the virus in our country now
I'd like to turn over this briefing to
dr. Nancy messenger who is the director
of CDC's National Center for
immunization and respiratory diseases
thank you dr. Redfield I want to take a
few minutes and let you know what the
CDC teams on the ground in Arizona
California Illinois and Washington State
have been doing to assist the state and
local public health department contact
investigations contact investigation
means tracing everyone who comes in
direct contact with the confirmed case
of this new virus it's essential that we
detect illness among contacts in order
to make sure that if these contacts are
infected that gets the best and most
appropriate care and they understand
what steps they must take to prevent
spreading of the illness to others
contacts are watched for signs of
illness from multiple days after the
last day that they were in contact with
a patient if the contact develops a
fever or respiratory symptoms they will
be tested to see if they are also
infected right now we have only a
handful of patients with this new virus
in the United States we're conducting
contact tracing for every one of those
patients because we still think this
strategy will allow us to contain the
outbreak and one that thanks the
patients here in the US that have noosed
new virus as well as their close
contacts for their cooperation during
these investigations I also want to take
a minute to thank our public health
colleagues at the state and local level
as well as all the health care staff who
have been caring for these patients our
ability to coordinate and react this
quickly is entirely dependent on those
collaborations but we here is not CDC in
isolation but our state local and
territorial partners as well as other
federal agencies as dr. Redfield said
right now we think the risk to the
general public in the United States is
low but risk is dependent on exposure
and while the vast majority of Americans
will not have any exposure some people
will and therefore will be a greater
risk of infection for example healthcare
workers caring for patients with
confirmed infection and other close
contacts they need to be vigilant and
the people around them need to be
vigilant as the secretary said there is
much we need to learn every day we learn
more and every day we assess to see if
our guidance or our response can be
improved as this response evolves CDC
will continue its aggressive Public
Health response strategy working to
protect the health and safety of the
American public I'll now turn it over to
dr. pouchy Thank You mr. secretary Nancy
I'm going to give you a brief snapshot
of the countermeasures in the form of
Diagnostics therapeutics and vaccines
that are being investigated and pursued
by the NIH by our grantees contractors
and y.a collaborators in industry first
with regard to Diagnostics the CDC has
rapidly developed a diagnostic based on
the published sequence of the virus the
NIH together with the CDC will be
working on next-generation Diagnostics
that are more point-of-care so that we
can get them more distributed to people
throughout the country in the world
next is therapeutics there is no proven
therapy for coronavirus infection yet
there are now ongoing studies that have
been initiated with the previous
experience we had with SARS and with
mares for example back then and between
those outbreaks and the current one a
number of
antiviral drugs have been tested in
vitro in some animal models and even in
the field anecdotally with historic
controls one of them is the antiviral
room des aveer which some of you may
remember was used as one of the elements
in the clinical trial against Ebola and
the other one that is now being used on
a compassionate basis by some in China
is kaliesha which is the combination of
two antiretroviral drugs again I must
emphasize there's no proven efficacy of
these but they are being pursued
together with the screening of a number
of other agents I might point out that
is why it is so important that we get
isolates of the virus which we will soon
have both particularly from the
individuals in this country who have now
been infected the five individuals that
you've heard of the other is monoclonal
antibodies when we were dealing with
SARS we developed monoclonal antibodies
as potential therapeutics again no
proven therapy because they would not
use they were only used in in vitro and
animal models given the somewhat close
homology between SARS and this and the
new novel coronavirus
there could be some cross reactivity
there that could be utilized however
what we're really trying to do and we
will have it soon as we get specimens
from individuals who are infected that
we will then be able to clone their
b-cells and make specific monoclonal
antibodies against the novel coronavirus
and then finally and most importantly
vaccines we have already started at the
NIH and with many of our collaborators
on the developing of a vaccine the one
at the NIH that I'll just mentioned very
briefly is in collaboration with a
company called Madonna and the platform
is a messenger RNA platform when the
Chinese isolated the virus they put on a
public database the sequence given the
technology of the 21st century we were
able to use that sequence pull out the
gene for the
I go protein spike of the particular
coronavirus and make that the Imogen to
be used in a vaccine right now that's
being prepared I anticipate with some
cautious optimism that we will be in a
phase one trial within the next three
months I want to emphasize because it's
sometimes confused going into a phase
one trial does not mean that you have a
vaccine that's ready for deployment it
will take three months to get into the
trial three months to get safety and
immunogenicity data and then you move
into Phase two what we do from that
point on will be determined by what has
happened with the outbreak over those
months remember we made a phase one
trial with SARS and we never had to use
the vaccine but nonetheless we are
proceeding as if we will have to deploy
a vaccine in other words we're looking
at the worst scenario that this becomes
a bigger outbreak so in summary there
are three types of interventions that
we're working on diagnostic therapeutics
and vaccines and we will keep you posted
as we make progress in each of these
thank you thank you very much dr. Fauci
dr. Redfield dr. Mattson yay
at this point we have time for four
questions from the media on the topic of
the novel coronavirus so Ricardo I'm
gonna start it if you'll wait a second
just because of the live-streaming to
get a microphone before you ask your
question thank you okay Ricardo Alonso
Zaldivar with AP and my question could
you please update us on what is known
about the asymptomatic transmission in
other words people catching it from
somebody who doesn't show symptoms and
could you also tell us how long after a
person is exposed does it take for the
testing to pick up the virus
let me ask dr. Matheny ada take that
sure thank you and those are really
important questions there have been
isolated reports of asymptomatic
infection from several countries those
are countries would only have a few
cases as opposed to for example in China
where the majority of cases are we're
looking at that data closely it's
important to know that right now in the
United States we have only five cases
and we have no evidence of
human-to-human transmission from those
cases those cases themselves traveled to
China and so that's an example of direct
transmission from China but that's
something we're watching closely and
obviously as more information becomes
available we would have to change our
operations if indeed that was a
significant issue in terms of how long
it will take from the time that you're
infected to develop a positive test what
I can tell you so far is that the
patients that we've seen in the u.s.
have tested positive and we're following
them but the way that we're looking at
close contacts is by doing more than one
test so that we can understand if for
example we pick them up initially and
they're not infected and then later on
they go on to develop disease as many of
you know that is something we do see in
other infections where there is a period
of time early where you have mild
symptoms before you go on to more
significant disease the PCR tests that
we have you know we've really rapidly
turned around from having sequences
available online to being able to get a
PCR it's a testament to CDC laboratory
ins ability to do something really
rapidly and I'm proud of them but as dr.
Fauci said we're gonna continue to work
on other Diagnostics that can also help
us to understand better the spectrum of
illness thank you very much how about
with the leather jacket here thank you
Robert Delaney with the South China
Morning Post I just wanted to follow up
on media reports that the White House is
considering travel restrictions from
China to the US and the other question I
had was about the offer to for the CDC
team to to support a solution by working
with the health authorities in China can
you give us some more information about
what the response from China has been
to that and who has been involved in
that interaction thank you so in terms
of in terms of travel restrictions as I
mentioned in my opening remarks it's
important to not take anything off the
table with a rapidly emerging novel
infectious disease we will be constantly
assessing the appropriate public health
measures to be taken based on the
science evidence and epidemiology that
we learn including some important
information is dr. Missoni a spoke about
and as I spoke about in my opening that
we hope to learn from by working on the
ground in China as quickly as possible
so we can see raw data raw evidence and
help design the types of studies and
analytics that really are needed that
leads to that your second question which
is the offer that we have made which we
do hope that the Chinese government will
take us up on that CDC experts are
standing by ready willing able to go
immediately to China either on a
bilateral basis or under the auspices of
the World Health Organization so I have
been directly engaged in those
discussions with Minister MA the Chinese
Minister of Health as well as with the
director-general Tedros of the World
Health Organization and he had the
director-general Tetris just had
meetings this morning in China so what
would be Tuesday morning in China with
senior most officials I found my
interactions with the Chinese government
to be very productive and cooperative
and I'm hopeful that we'll have a
positive resolution and be able to
deploy especially under the auspices of
the World Health Organization one thing
that we can do is let me ask dr. Moscone
to talk a bit about what we do when or
dr. Redfield what we do when our teams
go how we provide assistance with the
CDC currently we do have a CDC office in
China that's embedded in the China CDC
we would add our personnel there to help
them really define the epidemiology and
answer some of the critical questions
that were asked about asymptomatic
transmission for example in particular
and what is the incubation period since
there's been such a wide range we also
can assist them to begin to understand
really the spectrum of infection we've
developed a diagnostic test that we can
use to actually tell after the fact when
somebody has actually recovered were
they actually in
it or not so this is the critical thing
we do we we augment laboratory support
but most importantly we augment the
epidemiology capacity to answer these
critical questions that are so necessary
to understand for future public health
action in the green there is there talk
of appointing someone to a coronavirus
czar role so at this point this is a
public health issue our department is
leading this effort it's a public health
matter it is what we do it's our day job
is preparedness and response for public
health matters
we are tightly coordinated across the
interagency throughout the National the
federal government so as other
departments whether homeland security
State Department transportation commerce
we're all working together in a very
transparent way under the leadership of
the National Security Adviser so there's
a full interagency process but the lead
right now is very much a public health
preparedness and response activity led
by HHS thank you how about the there
chanting with United dnews group Taiwan
secretary Taiwan has confirmed a cases
already but Taiwan is excluded by WH o
would you be concerned that someone may
not be able to receive the latest
updates from WH o and how would you as
enhance cooperation with Taiwan on this
matter
thank you thank you so we always work to
ensure close collaboration with Taiwan
public this is a public health matter
not a political matter in any way and
certainly work to ensure the technical
technical expertise and exchange of
information happens and as the United
States can help to support that effort
we certainly continue that and then hey
mr. secretary Leavitt left stat you said
more transparency and more cooperation
from the Chinese government was the best
response so beyond allowing the CDC team
to join them there what measures would
you like to see that government take
that it hasn't yet so first having lived
through the SARS episode I can say that
the the posture of the Chinese
government levels of cooperation and
inner
with us is completely different from
what we experienced the 2003 and I want
to commend them for that they are still
obviously learning just as we are about
a rapidly emerging infectious disease
situation but getting w-h-o CDC experts
on the ground to be able to assist the
Chinese experts this is a major in a
major issue major public health issue
and we basically just need the best
Public Health people we have in the
world working on this right now and so
getting them there to do the types of
work that dr. Redfield and dr. Massenet
have spoken about in addition as dr.
Fauci mentioned the more actual isolates
that we can get actual live isolates we
can get the more robust we can ensure
any therapeutics or vaccines would be
more targeted and on top of the genetic
sequences that has been shared I mean it
is it is excellent that China put the
genetic sequencing online and complied
with the international health
regulations work that was what enabled
our teams at the CDC this was really a
historic accomplishment within one week
within one week the CDC had invented a
rapid diagnostic test within weeks we
have a candidate vaccine out of NIAID
that we're working on this is really
remarkable and that has two that rests
on a foundation of transparency and
collaboration under the international
health regulations sharing genetic
sequencing and isolates thank you yeah
the other thing is in the in the area of
research I mean everyone appropriately
is concentrating on the public health
aspects of it which are absolutely
critical but we've been collaborating
with Chinese scientists many of them
have actually trained in the United
States so it would really be very nice
if we could get more open interaction
not only in a public health arena but
also on sharing research data and
research endeavors so it's combination
of the two that's right here in front
here yes not wait for the mic please
yeah hi this is Shaun Appler from
Agilent sponsor press obviously we're in
a containment mode and firefighting mode
right now with regards to the corona
virus and learning more and diagnosing
but on a more on a broader level what do
what does this new corona virus tell you
about corona viruses in general and how
we can contain them
with regards to keeping wild animal
markets and and and and you know
consuming those wild animals should be
should this be the focus so that we're
not always looking for the next
coronavirus which is about to come out
thank you for your question I think
first I want to say and that it's really
important although we know a lot about
SARS and we know a lot about MERS we
really don't know a lot about this new
corona virus and I would be reluctant to
encourage people to translate knowledge
from those two viruses to this virus
that's the first thing that I would say
so as we learn for example we don't
actually know how this virus jumped into
into man bats are the most common
you know source of these viruses in
general so that's the larger assumption
but what what was there a second vehicle
or not and if so what it was like MERS
it's camels you know so I think we're
still learning and we're trying to you
know we're going to sort of stay where
the data is but I would just caution us
from taking lessons from MERS as a
pathogen and lessons from SARS and say
okay we know because neither of those
for example had significant asymptomatic
transmission and as was alluded to we're
trying to figure out is that just a rare
event or is it more so again I think we
just have to wait and see what we learn
over the next couple of weeks the black
blouse hi Breanna Ely from Politico I
was just wondering if you guys are
considering declaring a public health
emergency for the outbreak yeah so we
have we have various authorities that we
use one of them as you mentioned is
section 319 of the Public Health Service
Act which is a public health emergency I
will use that authority whenever I'm
it's recommended by our public health
officials that they believe any incident
is a sufficient stature to invoke it as
well as when the authority is implicated
by that are necessary I think it's very
important to remember where we are right
now we have five cases in the United
States
it's each of those individuals with
direct contact with Wuhan and no
person-to-person transmission in the
United States but I won't hesitate at
all to to invoke any authorities I need
to ensure that it to ensure that we're
taking all steps to protect the American
people
don't hesitate in the lease but I'll do
it when it's appropriate under the under
the standards that we have any
authorities that I need yes in the front
here
Wendy Jones NBC when will the additional
airport screenings start and the current
charter plane returning from Wuhan with
Americans will those people go into
quarantine in California and for how
long
let me ask dr. Nelson if you could take
the let me take the first part which is
as you know we have been over the past
week doing enhanced screening at five
airports specifically around travelers
returning from Wuhan what we're doing is
expanding our activities to 20
quarantine stations and really building
on our regular day-to-day activities
that those quarantine stations so our
regular activities of quarantine
stations focus on identifying ill
patients and that's what we're going to
be doing here
identifying ill travelers returning from
China so that we can make sure that
they're appropriately treated so that
they don't pass on this illness to
others but also it's an incredibly
important opportunity for us to educate
those returning travelers but the signs
and symptoms of this novel coronavirus
they are an important part of the
equation we want travelers to understand
that even if they don't have symptoms
when they come back to the United States
if they develop symptoms they should
contact their health care provider
immediately so that's a really important
part of this expansion identification
the bills passengers but an opportunity
to educate them so that they can be part
of helping us contain this disease and
then with regard to the the flight of
individuals who are connected to the
u.s. embassy consulate in Wuhan
returning with family members we will be
heavily engaged with that flight in the
transport of those individuals
they'll be screened evaluated constantly
there we physicians on the flight and
we'll take whatever the appropriate
evidence-based Public Health met
are with them as we would in any other
situation so well that'll all be
dependent on what we learn as we screen
speak to people as we do the type of
evaluation we would do in any type of
infectious disease contact tracing type
activity in the back there with five
hi Jason party from think global health
I wanted to ask about the rapid
diagnostic test is it going to be used
for routine screening and can you
comment on the efficacy of the of the
diagnostic given that the rapid flu test
produces false negatives over it yeah
thanks for helping me to clarify this
isn't the same thing as a rapid flu test
calling a rapid test but sort of it's
technically an rt-pcr a rapid real-time
PCR this is a test that is much more
sensitive and specific than some of the
rapid flu tests right now it's only
available at CDC and that's really
because before we roll it out to our
local partners we want to make sure that
it is as good as possible you know
developing a rapid test this quickly is
hard and if we're gonna pull it out
farther than CDC we want to be sure that
it has appropriate sensitivity and
specificity in this kind of situation is
it exceedingly important that we don't
misdiagnosed somebody and say that they
don't have disease when they do or
alternatively scare them when we do so
unnecessarily we are moving as quickly
as possible to get that test closer to
where the patients are and I expect that
to be available more locally within a
week or two and then hopefully
eventually as dr. Falchi was talking
about there'll be more availability of
these tests through other means but the
CDC tests as quickly as possible we're
getting it more local in the backyard
excuse me yep
thank you hi Lenny Bernstein like the
post over the weekend there began to be
concerns about containment within China
what's the latest thinking on that are
you feeling any different than say
Saturday or Sunday about the possibility
of this being contained within China and
given how few infections are outside
the country and no deaths does that tell
us anything about the lethality of the
virus so it's obviously spreading
rapidly within China I think at this
point I believe close to 50% of the Kate
the new cases are outside of the the the
one province where we've been focused on
but let me ask who bands are who've a
province with Luhan edit let me ask dr.
Redfield if he could talk a bit about
the evolving nature of the disease over
the days it's clear that the outbreak in
China is is continuing and I think you
those of you who are following the case
numbers know that was I think almost
1700 new reported cases like in the last
24 hours I think you've also seen from
the China response that they've mixed
and we talked about this word
containment and mitigation it's not like
there's a point where you switch from
one to the other we we integrate the two
and China's clearly moved to a number of
mitigation strategies that you know
advising or cancelling public large
events and large gatherings obviously a
lot of what they've done in terms of
changing travel areas so I think clearly
at this stage we have an ongoing
outbreak in China and we need to
continue to watch there clearly now is
evidence of human to human transmission
outside of that one province there's now
over 30 provinces in China that report
cases so again this is one of the
reasons we're hopeful that we can get
our experts in to work alongside to help
try to get a handle on helping them with
their broader containment strategy but I
do think it's a emerg thing between and
what they're doing from containment and
how they're starting to do certain
mitigation strategies I'm having the
front here oh yeah we'll go here first
in the front and then the other front hi
Tom rouse the ABC 7 News I had a
question that drug stores are reporting
they've had a run on people buying masks
I think it said increasingly likely and
another Republicans will will join those
of us who think we should hear from John
Bolton and whether but there are other
witnesses he documents well that's
another matter but I think John Bolton's
relevance to our decision has become has
become increasingly
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]